joe biden's homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas
spent the day completely embarrassing
himself
he just dodges questions about the
border crisis
and he just told us with a straight face
that biden is actually fixing the border
watch this
we inherited a broken and dismantled
system that is already under strain yet
we have effectively managed an
unprecedented number of non-citizens
seeking to enter the united states
managing it he's managing to break it he
inherited a strong border
to be exact
they're saying
they've really managed the one million
illegal immigrants that came through in
biden's first year a whole million of
them that's not even counting the got
aways so the white house pretty much
spent the year importing an entire state
of illegal immigrants it's true
one almost twice the population size of
wyoming
and vermont
but don't worry
our little secretary thinks it's all
under control and you shouldn't expect
that to change anytime soon
jeremy orcas do you believe frontline
agents and officers who consistently say
that they are poised to lose operational
control or some of some are all
america's southern border once title 42
is lifted we will not lose operational
control of the border
yeah you already lost it buddy
mayorkas justified trump's remain in
mexico program but his reasoning might
surprise you
i'm familiar with the migrant protection
protocols that the common language used
to describe that as the remain in mexico
program i so significantly and ardently
oppose it we received for example a
report of more than 1
500 incidents of murder rape torture and
other crimes committed against
individuals
who were subject to the remain in mexico
program
so the migrants were raping and
murdering each other
and then are we letting them into
lauren bobert is a republican
congressman out of colorado does that
make any sense to you congresswoman
jesse nothing about this regime makes
sense only that they are trying to
destroy and overwhelm our system and
look i know that this is an incredibly
serious topic we have an invasion at our
southern border but how can you watch
this guy come before congress and not
laugh he's trying to tell us with a
straight face he's effectively managed
the border look oj's lawyers would
probably turn down defending biden's
border policy even they have too much
pride and self-respect than to try to
defend what's happening at the border i
mean he comes before the house and tells
us he's spending millions on a wall that
isn't being built tells us that va staff
may be sent to the border instead of
serving veterans tells us that only
congress can solve his horrible policies
and actually thinks he'll be keeping his
job mark my words jesse secretary
mayorkus will be impeached if he doesn't
resign he will be impeached that's their
game they just lie remember they said
republicans were the ones defunding
police and the afghanistan evacuation
was top notch and was just going so well
i i don't think the american people buy
it especially when you see these visuals
you've seen this woman sprint into the
water
i mean this is a full tilt sprint to the
border and there's no one there to stop
her
jesse the american people are not being
deceived today we are at 2.5 million
illegals who have been caught crossing
the southern border under biden and a
modest projection is that there have
been another 700 000 that were got aways
meaning they got past customs and border
patrol and how many of those 700 000 as
you mentioned were on the terrace watrus
watch list how many of those got aways
were rapists and murderers we don't know
and that's the scary part we must secure
the southern border dhs is now asking
for all of this new money but it's not
for wall builders or agents who can
refuse entry no they want more money to
hire travel agents folks that'll say
hello mr drug smuggler here's a free
plane ticket to a city of your choice
also american taxpayers will be paying
for your health care schooling and legal
assistance that's what's happening here
jesse i've talked to border patrol
agents and they say folks with covid and
all kinds of other diseases tb and
measles are being sent through our
southern border and allowed into the u.s
you know that the next covet variant
that fauci is just waiting on so he can
tell everyone to mask up again
that that is coming through our southern
border and the biden regime is doing
nothing to stop it yeah they have
control over the border just like they
have control over crime and control over
inflation just a big mess and then you
have a
african-american border patrol agent go
there and try to rescue someone he dies
and you don't hear anything about it
it's a sad situation and we need to get
into jesse the most control that
the most control that i have seen is
peter cottontail directing the commander
commander-in-chief
the easter bunny's running the show
that's a sad state of affairs
thank you very much congressman bobert
thanks jesse we'll see you soon hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else